The FBI shut down "Silk Road",
the online drug site.
They called that a major victory
over drug abuse.
Silk Road generated more than a
billion dollars
in illegal business.
The most sophisticated and extensive
criminal marketplace
on the internet today.
Because people
bought drugs on the site anonymously,
Silk Road's founder had bragged
"the state is unable to
get its thieving
murderous
mitts on it."
But he slipped up.
He accidentally used his real name,
Ross Ulbricht,
on an internet forum,
and the state found him.
The FBI has arrested the reputed mastermind
of a popular online black market for drugs.
Then judge Katherine Forrest said
because “Silk Road was a black market
of unprecedented scope"
she would sentence Ulbricht
to life in prison,
with no possibility of parole,
ever.
He said, "Mom, it's a death sentence. It just takes longer. "
And he's right.
This is for all non-violent charges.
She and others say
it was unfair to lock Ross up forever
for a non-violent crime.
But why should we care?
Who was Ulbricht, anyway?
He seemed nice enough.
"Pretty sure I want to start a family
in the next five years.”
As a kid, he was a quiet nerd,
then an Eagle Scout,
excited to go to college.
But in college, he became
a libertarian.
And he wrote,
“I want to use economic theory
as a means to
abolish the use of coercion...”
Coercion, meaning force.
He viewed laws against drugs as coercion...
force that stops peaceful
people from
living the way they want.
"Show me your hands!”
He was right, but
many Americans hate and fear
drug use.
You’re breaking up the social fabric
of our country.
They applauded when the judge announced
Ross would be in jail
forever.
This is a judge that finally got it right.
Right.
Alright, we all agree here,
life in prison without parole?
Yep.
Anybody else?
Any other wise guys want to do it,
that’s what you're gonna get.
Give me a break.
Prison without parole is
not going to stop the sale of drugs.
We should have learned that from
America’s attempt at alcohol prohibition.
Once you’re an adult,
if you want to buy intoxicants,
it should be
your right.
Where that’s legal,
sales are done
without violence,
and the products sold
are safer.
This is your brain on drugs.
Yes, many drugs are dangerous.
Some who bought drugs on Silk Road
died.
At least six people died.
His mother said non-violent guy,
no
no.
Silk Road had some rules at least,
like nothing that harmed or defrauded.
No child pornography
was allowed.
But now that the government's closed Silk Road,
replacing the site with this notice,
other illegal sites have opened,
and they offer
more drugs.
These other sites, I've heard
that they're just open season, anything.
So they're actually worse
and
multiple times bigger.
She’d actually never seen them, so
we used the web browser Tor
to show them to her.
It's not like they got rid of these things.
Here's another one.
Hardly.
And by the way, Silk Road had 12,000 listings
when
it was taken down.
The new sites offer more than 100,000.
So I guess they weren't scared by Ross's
life sentence
as the judge said.
But law enforcement keeps bragging
about successes.
The dark net is not a place to hide.
Here’s Attorney General Sessions announcing
that they’d shut down
another website.
We will use every tool we have
to stop criminals from exploiting
vulnerable people.
But the shut downs hardly make a difference.
New sites appear.
Our critics will say
as we shutter one site,
another site emerges
and they may be right,
but that is the nature of criminal work.
It never goes away.
Never,
ever.
Heroin,
heroin.
So they didn't stop anything.
No, they actually,
there was a spike after the sentence was given.
It had the opposite effect.
It’s a
travesty,
what’s going on.
Still, I find it hard
to support her son since
he was also accused
of trying to kill people.
A murder for hire plot.
Trying to hire a hit man.
It's completely digital evidence and hearsay basically
by the government.
Ulbricht suspects an undercover cop
planted those messages.
A mortgage company
will not take a screen shot
of a bank statement
because they know
how easily faked it is.
No one was actually killed,
and the government didn’t charge Ulbricht
with murder-for-hire
in his trial.
Let's just say
for argument's sake,
that everything is true.
The typical for sentence for murder-for-hire
when there is no murder
because there were no murders
to be clear,
is 10 years.
Double life, plus 40 years
without parole
for a young guy who
you know, was a zealot.
He was a libertarian,
he believed in free markets
and volunteerism.
He's not a dangerous person.
No American is safer
because
Ross Ulbricht is in
jail for life.
He's just one more casualty
of our failing drug war.
Drug dealers shoot each other,
shoot bystanders,
and corrupt
whole neighborhoods.
Police! Search warrant!
The police risk their lives
and sometimes kill innocent people.
Locking up Ulbricht
won’t make anything better.
The drug war
does much more harm
than any drug.